yes off but ok ok well we're getting
started so everybody watching this is
the inspire movement first session with
rich and I've known rich for I don't
know how many years a number of years
dude is a great photographer video guy
artist mr. inspiration we've done a few
projects together but I wanted to start
off which maybe you want to just give
everybody a quick overview of what the
hashtag inspire movement is to you okay
sounds good i'll do my best it's still
work in progress it's developing the
whole vibe of it for me is i want to
create content and share content not
just myself my own but share confident
clay content that inspires people to
think for themselves to kind of to do
what what is their passion what they
love to do in life the kind of to be to
be doin have what they want to do in
life into kind of to be more than what
they may be right now and to share with
them whatever sources resources are out
there and whatever inspirational content
whether it's photography quotes images
videos to kind of push them forward on
whatever it is their mission is in life
so it's still evolving you gotta shorten
the the whole vision into a couple a few
lines that make sense in the very clear
so i'm working on that and i'm open to
your inputs long yeah that's a great
start and so the reason why i had to do
the hundred words is to try to get a
little more clarity okay and and it may
be inspires a feeling right so when you
watch something inspirational you feel
something yeah you know what's inspiring
to you yeah what now because we're going
to start a movement here mm-hmm we have
to communicate that and it's it's
putting that feeling into words that
make sense for you and for the people
yeah um you know i like i like what you
put together well you know the any I'm
not the judge it's it's got it this is
your movement not
right so like inspire believe are pretty
close yes dear sister movements we're
brothers were brothers and arms here in
the world but like having being able to
break that down would help would help
you and would help everybody watch it
too so um I think I'll believe okay
believe most people want to think about
believe they think about believe in
yourself for me believe is more than
that it's also believe that you're doing
the right thing let's follow your
passion right like believe in the work
that you're doing not just believe in
believe that you can do it okay right
like if you're if you're a stockbroker
and you hate doing a stockbroker you can
believe in yourself that you have the
skills but you're not doing something
you believe in man like you should be
doing something else so yeah leaving
believe in what you're doing and then
also believe that it's going to work out
so even if all you see is darkness and
you see no momentum and and like nothing
is happening they'll believe that it's
going to work out so those are the three
facets of belief for me the most easy to
understand the way most people find it
is to the belief in yourself the
self-confidence angle to it so you have
to define what the inspire movement is
all about this belief has a lot of
different connotations right that Justin
Bieber has is believed you know believe
believers believers uh there's a lot of
religious links to believe right Polly
I'm not believe in whatever right that's
not what I'm all about I'm defining
believe in a way that works for me so
you need to define inspire because
people come they think inspired what
what I think of inspiring aspire is you
see you you see something and you get
excited you know like you watch a video
you get excited you want to go make a
change in your life but like this other
facets to it that need to be broken down
and export a little bit more because
they have has a deeper meaning for you
than just one
so you talk a little bit about what you
posted like fun you said like this also
be fun yeah right so like how is
inspired and fun go together so you like
so that makes sense in your world but
it's now making that make sense
everybody else right I wouldn't have
necessarily put them together but you
did so this like you're defining what
inspire means to you yeah right so you
also have to do what you love do because
you love it not because you have to
inspires an evolution right so like this
is all great i'm not i'm not marketed
this is great yeah yeah so like one of
the three main ideas behind what the
inspired movement is all about well you
know what now that I'm on my third draft
of writing those hundreds okay I'm
trying to detach myself yeah you know
writing it in a way thinking right in
the way okay i'm writing this not to
impress anyone i'm not writing it to
Connor I all this my missions i'm
writing this for myself nobody ass
didn't read except for me yes it's
getting to that stage and i find that
now that last wrapped you got is closer
to a grime actually talking to myself
good where this is what I want me to be
yeah I do yeah and I guess in turn this
would be the the actual core of the core
values oh so for me inspires about
living an inspired life meaning living
and being doing what actually enjoy
doing what I want to do not because I
have to do it bills or because people
told me that I'm it's the only thing I'm
good at or this is secure or safe or I
some supposed to do this to get there so
trying to figure out how you can live
and inspired life and do what you want
is similar to yours similar to believe
the other thing with inspire is Turkana
inspire the movement with people in in
any industry any culture any any place
where it's not necessarily artists or
entrepreneurs or business people it
could be a fleets or musicians could be
anyone anywhere that just needs that
kind of that push or that support to do
to feel up yeah okay we're
doing the right thing right now even
though we're you know it's not popular
it's not people aren't really
understanding what I'm all about or
whatever people are putting my stuff
down that okay these guys you gotta love
Evan all these guys they're like pushing
us to their inspiring us to keep to a
vision because it's it's hard you know
you have a direction you want to go in
it's really weird it's strange you
you're one out of a hundred or a
thousand because everyone else is going
in a different direction so I find that
we myself and people like us can
constantly need stuff that inspires them
that sets them straight that supports
their vision and that tells them that
they're okay they're right they should
keep going where they're going even
though they're the only ones going this
way no no it's because that's one thing
I found on my path so I find myself all
alone I come on my own doing whatever
I'm doing cuz nobody else would do this
so it's a cooking maybe something's
wrong you remember she take it as a clue
that I should stop doing this because
I'm the only one but I think it's quite
the opposite isn't it it's kind of the
road to success and you know when you
get there you kind of on your own
because everyone's doing something else
so I think inspire would be to create
content to help people to figure out
okay we're on right track even though
what I want to do is is off what the
norm is it's the right thing for me to
do and how do you do that how do you
inspire people so that's kind of where
where I'm at now trying to figure out
how to articulate it how to word it
where it's it's it's a holistic vision
it's not just your business or your
career it's like everything in your life
so after I was saying life's supposed to
be fun because I want to find that angle
of how do you live and inspire that for
your having fun you're enjoying yourself
when you're working or having fun when
you're having fun you're having fun when
you're resting you're having fun so how
do you articulate that is a way of being
a way of living and that was a ramble
but no it's good man I'm feeling it with
with every every time you talk about it
every time you write it down it's going
to get clearer okay I remember with my
first company was a software company
we're looking to get some potential
angel investors and we got such a hard
time explaining
but we were doing if I was so complex
and we felt like you know what if we can
get somebody to sit down with us for an
hour we could explain it all and they
would love it and no problem we'd get
whatever we needed is usually doing
elevator pitches right you got like yeah
30 seconds and get something up and like
people don't have that kind of time to
give you so so that one that wasn't even
that long a ramble that was pretty good
it's getting better but it's getting
down still to the point where it's
almost the same thing you're saying each
time Oh is aesthetic so often and
because it it feels important to you
right so it's not it's not it's not um
it's not a sales pitch it's not here's
why you need to sign up her inspire yeah
it's like every word you're saying has
deep meaning you thought about it and
and when you say it gets you excited too
so it'll as you start talking about it
it'll it'll start melting into something
that becomes easier to say each time and
shorter and faster but you we're talking
to movement here this isn't just rich
living an inspiration you know inspired
feel of life happy fun feel like this is
now other people doing it and the stuff
that you create is helping them live
that kind of life so to create a
movement you have to make it easy for
people to spread your message right it
has to be easy for people to spread what
you're creating and so you know if you
can articulate it properly then there's
no way they're gonna be able to
articulate it right this is like there's
no way so it's giving that nuts that's
what was great about getting down to one
word it's at least that is easy to share
yeah before we got inspire it would have
been like this there's no it's all over
the place yeah i could write anymore so
at least we got it down to one word
which is great and now I'd love to get
it down to three concepts that the most
powerful concepts for you and maybe it's
living maybe it's fun maybe it's
perseverance maybe it's overcoming fear
you know three
important concepts that help define that
movement for you that means something
for you and then it's easier for people
to share that and then that helps guide
everything that you create okay well you
know what let me see if I have this dog
I'll get off my mind you tell me it's
going more in the direction because for
me inspires kind of more it's about a
way of life for me so it's kind of like
the way you do anything in your life
whether it's now having you know an
inspired workout so you may not do the
traditional kind of workout that regular
gym people do or the ones they preach
maybe you'll do something and workout
that's really unique to you makes you
happy is exciting not popular not common
but it's it's good for you and you'll do
that so it might be an inspired diet you
know sin you may eat you know you're not
a vegetarian you're not a vegan you're
not immediate area you're your own kind
of which is kind of the way I live my
life more or less than and more and more
each day is everything I do in life is
outside of the norm and I don't do it on
purpose it just that's what makes sense
to me instead of the stuff they were
yeah let me stop you there this is good
no I love that this is great inspired it
it's a would believe as a way of living
to an art that's a movement right
inspire is a way of living it has to be
it's not like you're only inspire half
the time yeah it's always on man you're
you are in your missing them are you
can't help it you you have a vein of a
different yeah right what you just
talked about like an inspired workout is
it you're different and it's okay to be
different you're inspired eating is your
different diet you're not a military
that's okay so for a lot of people
inspired doesn't have to be different
it's just inspired right I see I see
something and that that makes me
inspired to go out and and do the same
thing but it may not be different but
that that's cool man like your version
of it is you you want this different
angle to it right like you want people
to break out of their shell and and be
different
yeah you maybe got to one of the things
right like it's okay to be different
yeah and my thing has become
non-conforming not just do what you've
been told to do our trained to do do it
because you thought it through for
yourself and it makes sense for you
right because I fine for me most of the
stuff that I've been taught within
school parents teachers most of it was
not good or right for me so I have to
kind of unlearn everything yeah I'm
recreate everything for myself learn
everything on my own and figure out by
experimentation what works for me what
makes sense for me what inspires me and
that's what I do so everything I do is
kind of ass backwards you know it's good
I don't do anything normal it seems it's
good nobody it works for me it makes
sense for me and you have great personal
stories to share yeah I think I knew you
are this is a hard point for a lot of
people like you have great your you are
very self-reflective and you're willing
and able to find stories that you can
share and that's going to draw people
into a lot of people have a hard time
even finding the personal stories that
alone sharing them being willing to
expose themselves so you have that
vulnerability which will which will do
out for this which is great right so
it's it's people will have different
definitions of what inspire is so so
your ins you're creating your own
version of what inspire means because I
could you know some person might they
might listen to glengarry glen ross you
know they're there a salesperson they
listen of glengarry glen ross every day
that inspires him to go out and do their
phone calls but they're still doing the
same phone calls they were doing
yesterday like it's not that's not
inspire that's more motivated and
inspired although it's clear is similar
but motivated me you're motivated to do
the mission inspire it's kind of like
the way of life again for me yeah and
for some people like motivation that
could be a way of life to like
everything actually motivated to do
everything but so that's great like
that's a key difference for you that
helps define the inspired movement for
you is something has to be it has to you
want to create stuff that will make
people think behave acted differently
that's right
Byron evolution I feel is more accurate
inspire is is a little bit vague and
loose it could mean many things we're
inspiring evolution although it's a
little bit they need some explanation
but that's more in the direction because
you're right i do want to inspire people
to kind of do their own thinking and do
what makes sense for them as long as
you're not hurting yourself you're not
hurting somebody else and go for it yeah
so until now I didn't understand what
inspired and evolution meant okay you
wrote that I posted it it's on my life
site okay I didn't get it though so this
is the difference right you're going to
have your hardcore people who will love
everything you create will follow you
and when you write inspiring evolution
thats a good reminder for them that yeah
rich is right I got it I got it today
I'm going to evolve I'm going to do
something different because he gave me
that message but those are your hardcore
people the general public will look at
that and won't have any idea what you're
talking about okay so it's it's making
it easy for those people to understand
and bring them into the hardcore group
okay right so something like do
something different today is easier to
understand then inspire an evolution
yeah but they're both inspire for you
it's just they're both part of the same
umbrella it's not like do something
different is totally in a different
universe yeah so when you're talking
about it and you're creating content
you're sharing and videos and tweets and
all that stuff you can you can do both
like you want the stuff for the hard
core audience inspiring evolution great
ah but it might get lost on a lot of
people that's okay and then also have
the other stuff is that you think about
you think about a band right whatever
your favorite band is they have the
songs that hit I do well and that bring
people in and then you listen to the
rest of their album which might even be
the more meaningful deeper stuff right
like I we created that song that was too
poppy and whatever but it brings people
in it still is there stuff they're still
proud of what they made but the often
the more meaningful stuff isn't
song that hit it's like this unknown
song that the hardcore fans fine yeah so
that's like inspire evolution that's
like the harder to digest hardcore fan
easter egg stuff that they get and then
like think differently or live
differently or do something different
today is the easier to digest part but
regardless like that's one of the main
things that is different about inspire
for you then for maybe somebody else so
helps define it okay let me see if I
understand it are you meaning to create
two messages or like a different hashtag
or because I'm open if inspire isn't
perfectly clear I'm open to changing it
up I just couldn't figure out a better
word so cool i mean the audience doesn't
know this but we went back and forth on
words and everything a lot and you were
like obviously rich no i don't know this
is for you we like no no no no you were
you were pushing back and defending it
inspires your word that's cool man we
don't need to change that I'm just
saying add more clarity around it to
give three sub definitions like break it
down so that I understand what inspired
means to you because it's going to be
like inspire a different life I wouldn't
think that's not what I thought of
inspire I don't think it's the most look
if you look up inspire in the dictionary
I don't know if you're going to see the
word different no it might I don't know
I look I actually looked it up and
inspired this means to be filled with
the spirit the Spirit of God the
universe whatever be filled with spirit
connick enthusiasm be filled with that's
going to be the most when you say
inspire that's gonna be the most that's
what people are going to think so you
need to add further clarity to it for
what this movement is all about and part
of that is different okay so in the
making out more clearly talking to do
that in the 100 word kind of mission
statement yes in every day Oh what I
love the scene so in that hundred words
it's it's you know I'm
I have the three things right so three
areas that help define inspire for you
so being filled with the spirit right
that still is part of it for you but
then also different it's got to be
different like I want you to you know I
want to leave a different life outside
of the norm and then what up what's the
third one you know I don't know what
that is so maybe it's fun maybe it's
perseverance keep going maybe it's you
know don't worry what other people think
like whatever the third most you know
important thing is for you that helps
define it and there's going to be a
whole bunch of sister words that come
out of it too so don't worry I'm missing
this important one right that it just
helps provide some clarity because a
word like different is not going to be
associated by most people with inspire
but it is for the inspired movement that
you're creating this is Ritchie's
inspire right that's the difference
that's what we're trying to build and
then when you're creating content you
could you could create a video about
being different like you can create
posts about you can create a tweet to
say it's okay to be different or it's
great to be different hashtag inspire so
inspire doesn't have to be in every
sentence that you put out okay but it's
still it's still inspired for you right
it's still part of the inspire movement
but you're talking about these three
main areas and then the system words are
come of it so like if if if your third
one is fun like fun is part of inspire
has to be fun then you could you could
tweet out go out and have some fun today
it's important hashtag inspire because
let's inspire for you that's part of it
yeah makes sense right so if you only
focus on clothes and ideas that contain
the word inspire it's limited because
inspire is more than the entire movement
is more than the word inspired so you're
adding new definition and meaning to it
that's what people are going to get
excited about will want to share so when
my stuff
mrs. believe but a lot of the quotes I
put up have the word believe but a lot
of the other quotes and stories don't
have the word believe but it's all
believed to me it's all believe it's all
part of the same thing it's all part of
the same movement and my audience
follows along with it too so the same
thing for you and you're making videos
you have you have the champion one yeah
is that out yet yeah champion is I
haven't been promoting it but I really
said on youtube so like being a champion
is still part of inspire yeah I gave it
you you can't help but create inspire
content like creating a non inspire
content with would feel violence inside
their system yeah is that to you I work
so it's all inspired which is adding a
little bit more clarity for the people
who are following along and will help
spread your message for you um so in
terms of the content creation you have
you have your YouTube channel you have
what two videos that you put up there
under inspire so far too one video two
trailers one is a teaser trailer to the
video i made with you and believe yeah
and then the other ones a trailer for
champion then the full video champion
the channel is the first full video that
you put on your channel yeah but I've
got a half dozen videos pretty close to
complete and ready for it to be put up
on there okay they're just a matter of
hustling for what about Twitter and
Facebook what's going on I don't see a
lot of action here oh yeah this has been
my issue since the beginning of this um
you know the social media for me is I
haven't figured out how to click with
you get how to connect with it like i'll
start with it and i'll go for a little
while then i'll lose steam and look I'll
forget about I don't want to do anymore
not let it go for months so I've been
able to get some some you know some hits
and some people interested in stuff but
then i will keep up with it and I fine
for myself ugh I lose interest putting
it up so I haven't figured out how to
fully be immersed in it how to be
inspired doing it how to enjoy your new
so that's something I need to figure out
how to do what I would think about is
just like you're you're creating with
your videos what is the main message
that you want to put out it could be
I'll give you two options one is you're
taking some of the points you're taking
some of the ideas that we talked about
in 100 words yeah and just posting short
sentences and hashtag and inspired so
it's okay to be different or be proud of
who you are or have some fun today or
whatever it is like all something like
I'm making this up but like you read it
and you say yeah that that is meaningful
to me that means something and try to
put those up on your Facebook page and
your Twitter page that's option one and
this is establishing rich as let you let
me know what you stand for like you're
an expert and your I'm looking to you
for guidance you know I live I live a
crappy life and I want to be inspired or
under the great life and I still need
more inspiration like I'm looking to you
as mr. inspire I want your thoughts on
on the world right okay so as option one
option two is you just take since you're
making the videos already take
meaningful quotes from the video and
post those so I haven't seen the
champion one yet I didn't know was out
but I look at the believe I won that you
made and you know you have less brown
talking about the Chinese bamboo tree
this is a Jim Carrey top you know of all
these quotes if there's some quotes that
that mean something to you of them like
you put them in there for a reason
you're not just yeah that's a lot of
work man making those videos that's not
just now I'm going to go to youtube and
find some stuff right you have thought
behind each one and how you sequence
them together so you could take some of
the quotes that are being mentioned in
the video and tweet that out with
hashtag inspire put it on the facebook
app actually inspired so those are two
options the one is you are the thought
leader and ideally I'd like to see a mix
them it's
point but whatever is easiest to kind of
get you started because right now
there's nothing option one is you are
the you are you know the thought leader
we're learning from rich we're learning
what inspire means to him and you're
like you imagine you're talking to
somebody who needs help was not living
in inspire of life pick up pick a friend
pick somebody you know and what would be
the one if you have one sentence to wake
them up what would you what would you
tell them write that down right and it
doesn't have to have inspire arena put
your hashtag it right it's okay it's
going to work out keep going different
is cool whatever it is like your vibe
like I'm making some pop but your vibe
your words or take the quotes from the
videos and put them in and hashtag
inspire which one sounds better well I
like them both okay actually I think I
can only really sustain both geniuses
rather than one yeah I would be more
difficult to just do one of them it
seems to me then how both of mine issue
really is that part is easier for me to
figure out and put together because i
have a kvass database in my head and
also on paper boat and all that stuff
for me the main issue s i believe has
been that i have some kind of internal
conflict with what i do professionally
which is photography and videos film
stuff like that and then this whole
inspire movement is more of a passion
thing a fun thing I'm not a coach or
promoting myself as a coach or author
speaker anything like that nothing like
that at all so for me it's kind of a
disconnect between what i do when i post
photos of my recent work or when i post
a video i did for a client recently how
does that makes with all this stuff know
how does it all mix with this inspire
stuff where I'm putting out you know
quote by great people or even my own
quotes like where is that connect with
all the other stuff where we talking
about being different rich I know I know
it's something I haven't overcome yet in
my head I still have this block there I
mean you you want you can still say your
photographer right like so my my twitter
by was just I hashtag believe in
entrepreneurs yeah so you know I inspire
through
through photography and videos or
whatever it is right but you want people
who will your clients who love hashtag
inspire the clients that I bring on and
I work with I guess you don't work with
companies so much but I work with big
brands i would Google and Microsoft and
dental and huge companies who come to me
because they love the believe movement
like that's a value add it's not taken
away from anything it makes me different
which is okay to be different hashtag
inspire and it brings me business right
like this this will help bring you more
business and the right kinds of clients
okay and you can still like I think you
should post your quotes on top of your
pictures we talked about this yeah and
people say like where's that picture
from all this you got a lot yeah and
I've done that I've got a whole series
of them I just haven't released posted
man it'll it is here hashtag inspired
different life here we go I conspire
here you go and we going through my own
journey yeah to live in inspired letters
chairman it's important to share okay
dude I gotta get on a 230 call okay I'm
so you can book the time for next month
okay work on the three main ideas the
video is already going but I'd like to
see some stuff on Facebook and Twitter
and I will be following you and watching
and seeing what's up it's okay in some
progress and if you have any questions
whatever you want to try to shoot me
homie food sounds going to appreciate it
thank you very much for your time thanks
rich I'm excited inspire me to leave